[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king it's been a
minute
now we back up in it oh ho ho yes what
time is it what time is it oh it's fight
time baby you know what it is you see
what it is when the Grand Master's is
out it's a grand master fight about you
know what it is when you're Joey AG
listen you boys better start to listen
you know what it is so what we got right
now you got that barn burner we be
looking for right got that joint that we
be talkin bout right yeah you can't
still oh my god we got Deion saying
while the vs. Tyson Fury [ __ ] - why does
the first one had a little bit of drum a
little bit of action a whole lot of
satisfaction yours was getting it in ya
knockdowns
ya drag-out got a long count get it up
oh my god did you win controversial
decision wasn't uncontroversial my
decision got count
I gotta learn and count go back to the
old video I'll tell you how to count and
Beyonce wild is supposed to get that win
but the draw was alright so let's let's
let's break it out what has changed
since these two combatants these two
gladiators have gotten in the ring what
has changed
well let's start off with the champion
Deontay Wilder the bronze bomb up bomb
squad you know what he do so what he did
here two fights right for the mandatory
then he fought the most duck dude ever
what'd he do
knocked him out cold flat chopped me so
champions do they put in that work for
that hurt they're not playing Tyson Fury
what did he do well they signed a
contract with ESPN so we thought we
wasn't gonna get this fight it looked
like Tyson few was taking the money and
running not knowing that the pressure of
ESPN is typed crazy and said we're gonna
give you these two fights but you're
gonna do that run back you'll fight old
boy back it's okay Tyson fear you had
two fights one fight against a tomato
can no disrespect for anybody that puts
those gloves on their fights no
disrespect but you're not enticing fear
you love them so before the tomato camp
then the next fight fought another
cherry pick some off tree
Oh No takes a few yeah I get split yeah
yeah dad uh-huh
on his uh-huh wasn't looking too good
take some fear we had to cut that one
out 12-round decision he's looking at
money go down the drain me Spencer no no
no no no no no no you're not fighting
nobody else but Deonte hi
now let's rewind let's go back to the
first fight first fight that was Deontay
Wilder first pay-per-view nervous gonna
put on a big show had this big bloke in
front of him talking all this stuff
he's dude from overseas yeah all right
so he wanted to keep his knockout should
be going a lot of pressure on his back
people was dismissing his uh his boxing
powers not making no excuses for a guy
he went in there he stood he showed you
if he put balls on his head what
happened I mean come on man at this
point in the game we all know Deontay
Wilder like literally losing on the
cards and then BOOM flash boom by
everybody get up and go so you know how
that is first fight Tyson Fury it's out
there mangling jangling throwing that
jab came back from death he lost 146
pounds how come that man blood wasn't
tested how much diuretics did you have
to take to get off that way anybody that
has that struggle or weight understands
this fact that you need help period bar
none so you don't come back from
depression and drug addiction to not do
something else to relieve that weight
that fat big boys
status oh boy was more than three
hundred and eighty something pounds
no hard work dedication this Floyd's
model right
Floyd clean Floyd always been clean way
Tyson Fury got up off their campus in
the 12th round from getting hit with the
punch of Zeus shout out to my boy lemon
one away dragons TV go subscribe um it
was something in there man I don't know
so now we got to run back right so what
has changed in Deontay Wilder scamp
Deontay Wilder has put on a little bit
more weight no longer - oh wait - 17 you
might come in at 225 this fight still
slim trim ready to win
still got that knockout style but what
I've noticed about Deontay Wilder lately
he's been letting the knockouts coming
to him and it's more about form and
function remember he's a late blossom or
when it comes to this boxing game he
started fighting at 19 different type of
fight so he has the same camp same
people same people that brought him
through is the same people that he's
still whipped that means a lot let me
tell you chose one loyalty shows you
true respect shows three confidence in
your squad there's no dissension in
those ranks same people that was
training them feeding him conditioning
him getting him ready for the fight is
the same people that is in that corner
so there's a love of comfortability when
it comes to that corner when something
bad happens he has a security blanket we
all know fighters ego is fragile we all
know all athletes have a very fragile
ego this is where we get to Tyson Fury
this is where we get to the crux of the
matter
hold on put that chapstick boom get that
ready I so back at your boy Tyson Fury
Tyson Fury got rid of longtime trainer
Ben Davis Ben Davidson gets the outs
then Davidson was there when you what a
drug addict overweight you lost your
belts on the scale you lost your belts
cause yous unable to perform you you
lost your belt because of mental illness
you had to step away from the game had
there's been somebody else please man
no excuses so you ditched him for Sugar
Hill Lewis Emmanuel Lewis nephew from
the famous crunk gym not bad right not
bad at all he definitely has the boxing
acronym he's definitely done trained you
up so only one person is left then Tyson
Fury camp from his original strength and
conditioning coach
one person's left from everybody else
that roll with you all the way through
right okay let's get to what that means
that means there's nothing but yes men
around you that means one you do not
have any loyalty to yo team two you do
not have any confidence in your squad
three there was no respect for these
people earning a buck
they was witching News earning what
cheetos money now you're getting this
Doritos money do
I guess hiring other people from the
outside at a lower wage there's a little
bit better I felt kind of wait I'm never
one to ditch your team never one to
ditch a squad you go with who got you
here now here's the caveat Ben Davis
told that Ben Davidson told Tyson Fury
don't take the Deontay Wilder fight when
he took it Ben Davidson didn't have
confidence that Tyson Fury can pull that
fight off
that's why Ben Davison is gone because I
believe Ben Davidson was the one that
was vocal in the corner tongue boy don't
do this fight at all Tyson Fury took
this fight he had spent for some to take
this fight so none of the people he
hired is gonna tell him hey man it's not
a good idea to go up against the champ
so we expect Tyson Fury to come in a
little bit heavier he's been talking
this whole I'm gonna knock you out in
two rounds crap only person on that
stage is able to knock somebody out in
two rounds is Deontay Wilder
[Music]
I expect this fight to go no longer than
eight rounds with the WBC champion
retaining his belt by dramatic knockout
sidestep banger
it's combat talk with the king see you
next time
[Music]